- The app store is the world's
largest app marketplace.
(applause)
- Carplay will also support
third-party navigation apps.
(applause)
(running)
- Oh hey, we made it.
- [Joanna Stern] All right, all right.
You get the point.
Apple's annual developers conference
was a little bit different this year.
And by different I mean
there was no live audience
and it was streamed.
Yes, my dog was finally able to attend.
What wasn't different?
Two hours of new software features
for your iPhone, iPad, Watch and Mac.
I've rounded up the biggest announcements
by operating system, marking what I think
are the most exciting features,
and added some crowd responses.
For old time's sake.
(crowd cheers)
And also marking the most "meh" features.
(crickets croak)
Yes, denoted by crickets.
First up, IOS fourteen.
The biggest change?
You can now decorate and
organize your home screen.
There's new feature called App Library,
which will group your
apps into categories.
So you don't have to make your own folders
or flip through pages and pages of icons.
Your main home screen
can now be customized
with widgets too, like
weather or your calender.
(lady claps softly)
I'm also excited about
the new messages features.
You can now pin your most important chains
and you can reply to
specific messages inline.
(crowd cheers)
Also great, a new translation tool.
- [Female Speaking To Phone]
What are your store hours?
- [Phone] (Spanish translation)
- [Joanna Stern] The mass stuff,
well Siri no longer takes up
the whole screen.
Sure that's great, but its not useful
if the assistant isn't any smarter.
(beeping)
- [Siri] Sorry, I didn't quite get that.
- [Joanna Stern] And
then there are more ways
to customize your Memojis.
Including with a mask, because,
well because.
I have to say I was super excited
about all the WatchOS7
features we heard about today,
though I was left expecting some more too.
Yes its finally getting sleep tracking.
Like other wearables it will show you
your periods of sleep
and when you wake up.
And if you're worried about battery life,
well it will remind you to charge
when you wake up.
- [Male Presenter] Apple
watch is the first watch
to deliver automatic detection.
When you start washing your hands,
it's sensing how long you actually wash.
- [Joanna Stern] Yeah this
is pretty great because
counting yourself during hand washing,
is hard.
I can't say I'm psyched about this.
(crickets croak)
Plus with the global pandemic going on,
I was expecting to hear more
about some health features.
Perhaps that will come with the
next Watch hardware release.
iPadOS didn't get as many
features as in years past,
but Apple did fix some long time problems.
An incoming call will no longer
take over the whole screen.
You can also search from anywhere.
The Apple Pencil unlocks a whole bunch
of new handwriting features, so instead
of having to switch
between typing and writing,
you can now use the scribble feature
to write into search fields and more.
Yes things seem to be
more easily accessible,
but getting around is
still confusing in iPadOS.
Also, where is the multi user support
for the iPad, Apple?
Parents have wanted this for years,
and not on the Apple TV.
And lastly there is a lot of buzz around
the next version of MacOS, called Big Sur.
The operating system is getting
a full visual overhaul.
The biggest news is that Apple's moving
its Macs from Intel processors
to its own Apple Silicon.
Why are they doing this?
- When we make bold changes,
it's for one simple yet powerful reason.
So we can make much better products.
- [Joanna Stern] Well, specifically
it should make battery life better,
and yes there will be other
major performance improvements.
And the ability to run
iPhone and iPad apps natively
on the Mac.
Apple is working with app makers now
to start the transition, and it will ship
the first Mac later this
year with the new chips.
But Tim Cook also said there would be
more Intel Macs coming soon.
My reaction to this is both a little
(crowd cheers)
and a little
(crickets croak)
All in all, it was a
pretty packed keynote,
without me having to
go to a packed theater
to hear the news, and listen to a lot of
superfluous clapping.
I'm not sure why we haven't been attending
Apple events this way for years.